are you feeling superhero fatigue if you
are do yourself a favor go see Blue
Beetle this weekend and you might be
asking why because this is a very
refreshing movie it's not trying to save
the world it's not trying to save
multiple universes this is a smaller
film it deals with family values and
love and and heartbreak and perseverance
and dedication and overcoming those
obstacles in our life that will make us
better people that's what this film is
about and it reminds me of those
original superhero films we saw back in
the day like the first Superman movie
with Christopher Reeves in the 70s or
the the Spider-Man movie directed by Sam
Raimi starring Toby Maguire or even the
first Iron Man film and it even has
elements of Robocop in this as well so
for the more uh adult viewers out there
it has that element into it so it adds a
bit more of a edge to this storyline
but it's not a movie that we haven't
seen before but when you add the Latino
aspect to it you add the big family
aspect to it the family values you add
that a little bit of a love story and
this person becoming a great superhero
you put that all together even if you've
seen this story many times you're going
to want to see it again and you're gonna
walk out of the theater I think like
myself with a smile on your face going I
can't wait to see what they do with this
character now I wasn't a Blue Beetle fan
growing up I didn't even really know
much of the character saw him in a
couple comic books but that was pretty
much it I was a Batman Superman
Daredevil Wolverine kind of guy
so but I wanted to see this movie
because I am a fan of sholo mariduena
from Cobra Kai and I like George Lopez
and I thought you know what let's give
it a shot let's just try it out and I'm
glad I did because
this film hits on many many different
levels and the story is simply this it's
Victoria cord played by Susan Sarandon
she's the big bad CEO wanting to create
this ultimate police force by harnessing
the power from this Beetle Scarab this
ancient Scarab and you know put it into
these half man half machine beings to
create this Ultimate Force that's what
this movie's about and it's about Jenny
cord her niece the daughter of Ted cord
the former Blue Beetle who's no longer
with us in this movie
um she doesn't want the company to go
down this direction she wants the
company to be what her father wanted it
to always be is to help those that need
help and so there's this battle and she
takes the Scarab from her aunts from the
court Industries and she bestows it on
Jaime Reyes played by sholomari duena
and that's essentially the beginning of
the story now there's other elements I'm
not getting into all of it right now
first let me talk to talk to you about
this
um her name is Bruna marquezine
Brazilian actress who plays Jenny cord
she is fantastic this girl is not only
breathtakingly beautiful she's a good
actress and when you see her on screen
the moment that she pops You're Gonna Go
wow what do we have here it's kind of
like that moment I don't I'm gonna show
my age a little bit when we watched you
know Zorro with Catherine Zeta Jones and
everybody was like who is this woman wow
or Margot Robbie and Wall Street it's
that kind of moment that when you see
her come on screen she has that she's
gonna be a massive star I guarantee it
uena
fantastic in this world huge fan of him
in Cobra Kai in this he owns it he is a
leading man and I wasn't too sure if he
was gonna be able to pull it off but he
does beautifully he's got Charisma he's
got the looks he's got the physicality
when he needs a habit he's got that that
passion and he's got that emotional
um that depth inside of him as a lead
actor you are on board with him and I
hope they do more with his character
because if they don't it is a uh it's a
big mistake on on the DC side of it
because he really does make you go Blue
Beetle is a character I want to see more
of that's talking about some of the
performances and before we go further
here's a quick message from our sponsor
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of Chess but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of four men function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
we gotta talk about the family here the
Reyes family now this is an ensemble
cast there is one that is a standout and
rightfully so it is George Lopez he is
awesome as Uncle Rudy in this and uh I
mean George Lopez is a brilliant
comedian anyway and he's a good actor as
well look I grew up in Las Vegas and I
lived in Southern California so I had a
lot of Latino friends a lot of Hispanic
friends and I've been to their homes and
had meals with them and hung out with
them and I met their relatives and if
you're like me or even if you're a
Latino yourself watching this video you
are going to laugh your ass off at some
of the things that go on in this in this
movie because on hell knows what he's
doing by creating this Latino family
unit here and they really are the heart
of this film in so many ways
that you're going to you're going to
laugh out loud and you're going to cry
and he does it brilliantly and George
Lopez just steals almost every scene he
is in sometimes he's over the top but he
knows he's over the top and he plays it
up to the point where you just laugh out
loud and I I wish I was in America
watching this movie I'm in Singapore of
course but in a in a movie full of
Latinos and Hispanics watching this
because they would be laughing their ass
off at this thing it is hilarious now
there are parts of this film where it
does start becoming a little bit silly
for its own too good but the director
does pull back and he does kind of bring
it back to a little bit more of a a more
grounded reality of course as a
superhero film so not everything is
going to be grounded and some of the
things that happen in this movie are a
little bit like okay that's a little bit
too much but you go along with it
because it's a fantasy movie it's a
superhero movie not everything is
supposed to be it's this is not
Oppenheimer okay it's not even the
Batman it's I'm much more Fantastical
Movie than that but you go along with it
because you're having a good time and
that's what this movie brings to you
it's a good time and you go along this
journey of Jaime becoming the Blue
Beetle and his relationship with Jenny
and how two people from Polar Opposites
of the spectrum from this wealthy you
know Billionaire's daughter to this this
kid who graduated University his
family's losing everything their home
their family business the father is not
doing well health-wise how these two
join together they work and the
chemistry between these two is on fire
these two really when they look at each
other you're like wow okay here we go
they're nice no I mean but that helps
sell the film it really does overall I
really enjoy this I'm not going to give
away too much if you are a fan of the
Blue Beetle mythology they do dive into
that so that is addressed in this there
are two post-credits scenes of this by
the way and the first one is very very
important the second one not so much
does it tie into the Snyder verse not
really does it tie into the new DCU
Universe hard to say we haven't seen any
of the films from it I mean I believe
this is the first film of the DCU but
there are references to you know
um
I mean there are references to other
superheroes out there but there's no
faces to them so it's kind of a blank
slate on that regard so the big physical
bat of this movie
um he's got an interesting storyline to
himself I mean you first see him he
seems like a one note character but I
think the build up to his
finale in the third Act is really really
good and it sets the stage for Jaime
also coming to terms of who he is as
Blue Beetle and I think that's enjoyable
to watch so what I recommend it yes
definitely check it out and support this
film the actors can't support it so it's
up to us reviewers out there to get the
word out but I gotta give it to the DCU
and the James Gunn and Peter South run
into of course the entire team behind
this film you guys created a very good
movie support it get out there watch it
this weekend and let's get the box
office up for this because it does
deserve it and I hope to see more Blue
Beetle anyway guys those are my thoughts
in the movie let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below and if you
like my movie reviews check out more of
them right here
thank you